(host)
What looks like
a reptile amphibian hybrid,
has a dish shaped skull,
smells like fish, is childlike,
and out to steal your crops
and drown your livestock?
The Japanese water yokai, kappa.
Kappa translates
to "river child,"
but there are more than
100 variations of the name,
and while described as
childlike in appearance,
their behavior
certainly is not.
Kappa is a truly
Japanese yokai.
While some yokai
originate in China
or are inspired by
Chinese folklore,
the kappa is Japan
through and through.
And kappas are obsessed with
butts, so hang on to yours.
I'm Dr. Emily Zarka,
and this is "Monstrum."
With so many different
stories of kappa out there,
I knew I would need
some extra help
digging into the lore
of this yokai.
My name is Yoshiko Okuyama.
I'm a full professor
of Japanese studies
at the University
of Hawaii at Hilo.
And I'm also the author of
"Japanese Mythology in Film."
Personality-wise, the kappa
is like the class clown,
with a penchant for pranks.
Sometimes, a really bad one.
According to legend, living
in rivers, ponds, and lakes.
Kappa are commonly
portrayed as green in color
with a turtle shell
on their back,
partially hollowed-out heads,
and beak-like mouths.
A popular kappa
story is based on
a real Japanese feudal lord,
Kato Kiyomasa.
After a kappa drowns one
of his favorite pages,
he orders the execution of all
the kappas in his province.
Buddhist priests chanted to
keep the creatures in the area,
monkeys were brought in
to frighten the kappa,
and all the streams
were poisoned
and filled with hot rocks.
Scared and sick, the leader
of the kappa promised his kind
would never harm anyone
in the region again.
They were forgiven
and kept their word.
This is a common trope
in kappa tales.
Oftentimes, kappa must promise
to stop harassing people,
and they must offer help
to people when needed
or share their secret
medical remedies.
The kappas were
especially adept at
bone setting, oddly enough.
Their medical knowledge
may connect back to other
water deities associated
with fertility,
or agricultural deities,
especially in more
positive legends,
since they were also given
offerings in the hopes
of securing good
health in children.
Outside of making threats,
there are a few other
ways to survive an attack.
Sometimes, a kappa attack
on a human or livestock
is foiled when the yokai's arm
is pulled out of their bodies.
Luckily for kappa,
it can be reattached.
But they have
a critical weakness.
If they spill any of the liquid
from their unique head dish,
it's going to be a problem.
Let's talk about
that for a second.
The kappa's head has
a divot that holds a liquid
directly related to
the kappa's life force.
You can defend against a kappa
attack by wrestling the kappa
or just by showing some manners.
If you bow before your
opponent, it will bow back,
spilling the contents
of its head dish
and losing its strength,
and maybe even its own life.
Another bizarre attribute of
the kappa, it loves cucumbers,
which is also the reason why
a cucumber sushi roll
is called kappamaki,
a fun little reference to
this mischievous yokai.
Less fun fact, if the kappa
pulls you underwater,
it will steal
your liver or blood.
They will often
do so by a rather
non-traditional backdoor method.
Why? Well, they must remove
the shirikodama first.
The shirikodama is
a mythical ball-like organ
or jewel that people have
inside their derrieres.
(Yoshiko)
That's the source
of your vitality,
like your life's battery pack.
And Mr. Kappa wants it.
Once it snatches your
shirikodama, you are out.
Your body
becomes like a noodle,
all weak and floppy
in the water.
Ah, talk about a bizarre way
to lose your mojo, right?
And a way to make it easier
for kappa to drown you.
Apparently, this is
a tasty snack for kappa,
who will consume it or take it
to their king as tribute.
And yes, some read
earlier kappa lore
as symbolic of male-male
sexual relationships.
There are a lot of kappa
stories involving butts,
but let's save that
for the comments.
The kappa is often associated
not just with violence
and thievery, but sexual
harassment and assault.
Kappa are almost always male,
especially in the earlier lore.
According to author
Kunio Yanagita's
folklore collection,
"The Legends of Tono,"
the kappa will attack
and impregnate human women.
The offspring of these attacks
are mercilessly killed,
chopped into pieces,
and buried in wine casks.
There are a lot of regional
variations of kappa
given its large
geographic range.
They're often depicted
as an amphibious creature.
Japan is home to over
30 species of frogs
and 17 types of turtles,
so an amphibious water
yokai makes sense.
In Eastern Japan,
kappa commonly
had a turtle shell
on their back,
while in Western Japan,
variations were more likely
to be covered in hair
and walk upright.
I think these kappa might
be more heavily inspired
by the Japanese
macaque or snow monkey,
who just so happens
to like to take
hot spring baths in the winter.
The association with kappa
to drowning humans
seems straightforward.
They might've been
used to warn children
to be careful around water.
(Yoshiko)
Think of the kappa legend
as ancient Japan's version
of a no swimming sign.
Back in the day, a written
warning wouldn't cut it, right?
Since most folks couldn't read.
But a chilling tale of a
life snatching water creature
would stick in your head.
And they're a reminder
to protect livestock.
Those are valuable resources
you wouldn't want to lose.
Makes sense, but there's
a bit more to it.
In Northern and Eastern Japan,
the kappa more commonly
pulled horses into the water.
In these regions,
horse populations
were much higher than cows.
Even going as far back
as the 13th century,
there's evidence of horse
veterinarian clinics in temples,
a clear sign
of the equine's importance.
But over in Western Japan,
the stories center around
kappa attacking cows.
This region's leather trade
was largely dominated
by cow skins,
and boasted the epicenter of
the Japanese leather trade.
Whether cows or horses, the
kappa's threat is significant.
In the 17th century,
an unparalleled
set of laws existed
to protect these
and other animals
from maltreatment.
It was illegal to abandon
a sick cow or horse,
and certain rules existed around
how to dispose of their corpses.
In the late 18th century,
reports emerged of peasants
in rural communities being
charged additional fees
for corpse removal if
the animal dies in fires
or from drowning.
A kappa pulling a horse or cow
to a watery grave
would be significant.
It meant a loss of a valuable
asset and a potential fine.
In the early 18th century,
written folklore of
the kappa developed,
and it gave us the first
recorded images of the monster.
Around 1713, Terajima Ryoan
compiled a truly
extensive encyclopedia.
At a whopping 105 volumes,
the entries are accompanied
by illustrations,
including his take on
a creature labeled kawataro,
which is widely considered to be
the first illustration
of a kappa.
This important entry into
yokai lore is very detailed.
Described by Ryoan as about the
size of a 10-year-old child,
it speaks in a human voice,
walks upright,
and has a partially concave
head that can hold water.
While they favor
a watery habitat,
they are not above making
their way onto land
to steal crops or enjoy
a little sumo wrestling,
a sport they excel in,
as long as the top of their
head is holding water.
Ryoan also mentions
the butt stuff,
as in sucking blood from cows
and humans through their butts.
That might sound
ridiculous to us now,
but keep in mind that
yokai were presented in
academic texts alongside
real world animals.
This blurred the lines
between folklore and fact.
That tradition would
change slightly in 1776
with the publication
of the first
yokai-exclusive bestiary
in Japanese history,
and you better believe
the kappa is in there.
Author and artist,
Toriyama Sekien, also added
another detail to existing
kappa lore: webbed feet.
With the publication
of this text,
the kappa became more
rooted in folklore
rather than real history,
and less associated with
danger and deviance,
serving more as symbols
of Japan's rural history.
And that symbolism
carried into modern times.
For example, the 1923
novella, "Kappa,"
written by Ryunosuke Akutagawa,
uses the fantastical
land of the kappa
as an intentional caricature
of post-World War I
Japanese culture.
Other 20th century creatives
also depict the
creatures walking upright
and acting in more
human-like activities,
a trend that dominated the
kappa of popular culture
after Shimizu Kon's
"Kappa Tengoku"
introduced the kappa
into manga in the 1950s.
The series centers
around a family of kappa
engaging in everyday
human behaviors.
They eat,
shop, and go to work.
It was in this
decade that Shimizu,
along with artist, Kojima Ko,
standardized the female kappa.
Making kappa more
human pushes them
further away from being
a monster to fear.
Lighthearted versions continued
to appear throughout the 1970s,
where they recalled
a nostalgia for rural life
and traditional
Japanese folklore.
Rural regions of Japan
publicized kappa legends
to encourage appreciation
of traditional
Japanese communities and
boost their economies.
One of the most popular kappa
tourist destinations is Tono,
which just so happens
to be an important site
for the historic Japanese
horse trade back in the day.
Kappa continued to
appear everywhere.
Anime, manga, books, and live
action and animated films.
They appear in
advertisements and logos
for everything from
sake to credit cards.
Their more nefarious origins
have turned into
a nostalgic nod to the past.
And they sometimes move
beyond Japan's borders.
In 1993, "Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles III"
takes the anthropomorphic
turtle brothers
through a time traveling plot,
where they are constantly
mistaken as kappa.
Kappa even popped up
in everyone's favorite
cozy escapism game,
"Animal Crossing."
We also see evidence of
the kappa's popularity
in a form of modern day
encyclopedia, the database.
If there's a fandom out there,
you can be sure there's
a fan base website describing
and categorizing the
minutia of its universe.
The Pokemon wiki,
monster wiki, or the D&D wiki,
the kappa appears
in all of those.
These collections of fan
knowledge aren't just about
modernizing the bestiary
or encyclopedia,
they're part of a global
desire for connection.
The appreciation
for the folklore
and its evolution can be
shared around the world.
And kappa in particular holds
special meaning in
Japanese history.
(Yoshiko)
As I stated in my book,
"Japanese Mythology in Film,"
we have this innate desire
to preserve our
cultural traditions,
our ancestors' beliefs, customs,
and even spiritual practices.
These are like the tapestry
of ancestral wisdom,
woven with newly
enriched thread,
as they are passed down from
generation to generation.
I don't know, something tells me
Terajima Ryoan would be proud.
I just said boasted,
not boosted.
It is boasted!
'Cause it would've
boosted the leather trade,
but it boasted.
David, you sound so positive.
-We gotta go back to the top.
-We got it, we got it!